In the last video, we left
off with the assassination
of Archduke Franz Ferdinand
of Austria, the heir
to the Austro-Hungarian empire.
And so you could imagine,
the Austro-Hungarian empire
did not take that well.
They already did not enjoy the
kingdom of Serbia trying to,
essentially, provoke this
nationalistic movement.
And they viewed them as this
small, little, weak country
right below them.
And so they use this
to, essentially,
issue an ultimatum.
Essentially say,
look, immediately
bring all the people
who did this to justice,
all the people who might have
conspired with the Gavrilo
Princips to allow
this assassination
attempt to occur,
and do it or else,
and accept full responsibility.
And actually, the
kingdom of Serbia
was in no mood to get into
a war with Austria-Hungary,
and so they tried
their best to comply,
but their best wasn't enough.
So then July 28,
a month later, you
have the Austrians declaring
war on the Serbians.
Now up until this point,
the Austro-Hungarian empire
is thinking, OK, Serbia is a
small, little kingdom here.
It has some ties and
obviously, it's a Slavic nation
so it has some linguistic
ties with the Russian empire.
The Russian empire also had
some political ties to it,
but Russia is not going to get
into a war with us over this.
We're justified
in attacking them.
They've just killed
the heir to our throne.
So we're going to go in there
and Russia is probably not
interested in actually creating
a larger skirmish here.
That was a severe miscalculation
on the part of the Austrians.
The Russians were
not happy about this.
They felt close
ties to the Serbians
and they felt a need to
protect the Serbians,
or you could argue,
that maybe they
wanted to mobilize just
to scare the Austrians.
Whatever it might be,
whether it was Russia
wanted to get into a war,
whether they were really
looking to protect the Serbians,
or whether they were looking
to mobilize to scare the
Austrians from actually
attacking, the Russians
began to mobilize.
So the Russians began
to gather their troops.
So the Russians mobilize.
And now, this is where
all of the alliances
start to come into effect.
If you remember
about the alliances
we talked about several
videos ago, if you go to 1879,
you have the Dual
Alliance Treaty
between Germany
and Austria-Hungary
to protect each other if
Russia attacks and actually,
if Russia attacks or mobilizes.
So now, Germany is
like, hey, maybe I
am obligated to protect
Austria-Hungary from Russia.
You also have to remember
in 1892, the Franco-Russian
Military Convention.
Military assistance both
ways in the event of attack.
So Germany is thinking,
look, we signed this treaty
and we, to some degree,
are maybe eager for war
because we've been
militarizing so much.
And I can't just fight Russia.
I also know that
France and Russia
have this alliance
right over here.
So Germany in quite
surprising quickness
decides to declare war on both.
So on August 1, Germany
declares war on Russia.
And then on August 3, Germany
declares war on France
because they know
or at least they
feel that they can't declare
war on only one of them.
And they wanted to do it very
quickly because they didn't
want Russia a chance
to mobilize too much.
And the fact that they were
able to do this so quickly--
we're talking three days after
Austria declares war on Serbia
and then another
two days declare war
on France-- kind of shows
that Germany was already
in a war footing.
It's not a joke to
all of a sudden invade
or declare war on countries.
So Germany was, essentially,
preparing for this.
And this right
over here gave them
the excuse to,
essentially, declare war.
So they declare war on both
of these characters, Germany
against Russia.
Germany is declaring
war on France.
Now, the easiest way for
them to move into France--
so they're literally
going on the offense
here-- is for them to
go through Belgium.
But the Germans were aware.
They're aware that there's this
75-year-old treaty, the Treaty
of London in 1839,
Article 7 said
that Britain was to protect
the neutrality of Belgium.
And Germany was in
no interest to get
into a war with the British.
The British had a
powerful military,
especially a very powerful navy.
The Germans said,
hey, let's just
take on the Russians
and the French for now.
And so they actually
reached out to the British
and said, hey, this little
treaty that you got here
from 1839, this
75-year-old treaty,
you don't really take
this seriously, right?
I mean if we have to
go through Belgium,
you're not really going to
hold true to this treaty?
And the British
said, no, we actually
take that very seriously.
Obviously, the
British didn't want
the Germans to be
aggressive here.
The British didn't
want the Germans
to be able to invade France.
And so on August 4 when
Germany, essentially,
rolls through Belgium,
Germany invades
Belgium to get to France, this
gave the legal justification
for the British to
declare war on Germany.
And so in a matter of only--
I mean not even, we're
talking a few months here from
the assassination of Franz
Ferdinand of Austria,
you essentially
have all of the major
powers of Europe.
And then as we'll see because
they had these empires, in not
too long most of the world
is at war with each other.